You, yourself, actually have someone
that you choose your battles
to tap into some wisdom.
Are you gonna let me name drop here?
Yeah.
Yes.
Do it, go for it.
Are you talking about my good friend and mentor,
Dwayne The Rock Johnson?
I am!
Oh.
Oh, yes, yes.
I am, and I am such a fan of his.
I am fangirling out.
I would love to know one piece
of Dwayne The Rock Johnson advice
'cause I really respect him.
You know what?
He's given me a lot of great advice in my career
at moments I really needed it.
Whether it was changing my moniker online
from an alias to Lilly,
whether it was deciding to do the late night show,
I actually asked him for advice.
And I'll give you the advice he gave me then,
because I had called him and I had said,
"I'm really nervous about this opportunity.
I don't know if I should do it."
I was on the fence.
And I said, "I don't wanna be pigeonholed as a host now,
as someone who just is gonna be behind a desk.
I have aspirations to act and write."
And he said to me, "If you were gonna be pigeonholed,
you would've already been pigeonholed as the YouTube girl,
and you never let that happen."
And so I was like, "Okay, yes, sir."
(audience clapping)
I love that, I love that.
Okay, well, last but not least,
I have dark circles under my eyes
and I let my girls go to bed way too late,
because we were up watching
"The Bad Guys"!
Yay!
Did you like it?
This is such a good film
with like Sam Rockwell, and Awkwafina, and Marc--
Marc Maron, yeah.
Marc Maron.
And Lilly Singh, a stellar cast.
And it's just a really good script,
it's getting very well reviewed.
Y'all it's bomb.
When I watched it for the first time,
I knew it would be good,
but I was laughing out loud, it was hysterical.
This is a great movie.
And may we all
find our shape in the right formation.
And remember that when we go like this
that we can get ourselves back to this.
Yes, thank you.
(audience clapping)
Her new book, "Be a Triangle," is out now.
And "The Bad Guys" is premiering April 22nd.
My dear friend, Lilly Singh, I admire you so much.
Please keep speaking the wisdom.
Please keep making us laugh.
And please keep doing everything that you see fit to do.
We'll all follow and beyond.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)